خالد وين راحت
ورايحه
الذي سلم عليهم يابا واطلب شفاعتهم شفعهم
خليهم يشفعوا نا يا رب انتقلت يابا لعدل
الله المطلق انتقلت من ظلم
الدنيا من ظلم الدنيا انتقلت يابا لعدل
الله
المطلق المؤسف عليها الدنيا يابا ه اللي
فيها موازين
الكون موازين غاب يابا هذا عريس انا
اهديته لفلسطين وجدت بدمه من اجل مرضاه
الله عز وجل فلسطين بدها والارض بدها
واحنا بتراب الارض هذه ممولين ومتجذر بهذه
الارض لا قتل ولا حتى فلذات اكبادنا لما
بروحوا منا بدونا تجذر وزدو تعم في هذه
الارض ارض ارضنا هذه هذه الاغنيه اللي
ورثناها عن ابائنا واجدادنا ورثناها
لاولادنا وح نورثها لاولادنا الصغار
وصغارنا حورث لاولادهم لما
يكبروا اللهم اجرني ب موصي واخلفني خيرا
منها طخو لي اياك ويوم عيد ميلادك يما
وطلبتك من الله يرد لي اياك ورد لي اياك
بريقي منك
ياما
والحمد
لله احمدك واشكرك على اطاك ورضاك يا رب
زفو الشهيد زفوه وبعطر المسك رشوه بالكفن
الابيض لفوه وراحوا لرب ودو زخريا مات
الشهيد ماركوني يا عالم في انس ابني شهيد
ادك واشكرك على فضلك ورضاك يا الله اللي
بحب ابني ما يبكي عليه
يعيله الصبر من
[موسيقى]
عندك
ير
[موسيقى]
ج
هناهم
هنا يا حبيبي يا الله يرحمكم
ياماك الله اكبر عرا لا اله الا الله الله
اكبر عزرائيل لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ير الله
اكبر
اكر عليك يا اسرايل الله يكسرك يا اسرائيل
الله يكسرك يا اسرائيل